and they heard the voice of the Lord God
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day and Adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the Lord God
amongst the trees of the garden that's
interesting so what's the implication
prior to being woken up prior to
recognizing nakedness and vulnerability
there is no reason for God for men and
women to hide from God now are they
hiding from God while they're naked
they're vulnerable
okay so think about this think about
this it's like imagine that you have the
capacity to live truthfully and
courageously and forthrightly just
imagine that and then imagine why you
might not do that and then imagine how
about fear and shame how would that work
well let's say that the idea of living
forthrightly and truthfully and
courageously is analogous given what we
already know about these stories -
walking with God in the garden what
stops people from doing that what stops
people from hiding well it's their own
way it's a recognition of their own
inadequacy they look at themselves and
they think how in the world is a
creature such as I supposed to live
properly in this world with everything
that's wrong with me and so what do you
hide from well you you go home you sit
on your bed for five minutes and ask
yourself what have you hidden from in
your life man you'll have books of
knowledge reveal themselves to you in
your imagination right say well why are
you hiding
well it's no bloody wonder you're hiding
it's no wonder that people hide that's
the thing that's so terrifying about
this story we woke up and we thought oh
my God look at this place like this is
seriously there's some serious trouble
here and we're in some serious trouble
and we're not what we could be and so we
hide and that's what the story says
people woke up they became self
conscious they recognize their own
vulnerability and that made the made
them hide from manifesting their divine
destiny it's like yeah that's exactly
right and the Lord go there I love this
part of the story and that's so funny
and the Lord God called and we could use
a little humor at this point and the
Lord God called unto Adam and said unto
Him where art thou and Adam said I heard
thy voice in the garden and I after I
was afraid because I was naked so in
case there was any doubt about that
that's why and I hid myself
and God said who told you that you were
naked
did you eat of the tree where have I
commanded you that you should not eat
and this is where Adam shows himself in
all his post-fall heroic glory and the
man said the woman whom thou gave us to
be with me she gave me of the tree and I
did eat
so that's such hurt man that's such that
it's so you know again there's a modern
feminist interpretation of the story of
Adam and Eve that makes the claim that
Eve was portrayed as the universal bad
guy of humanity for disobeying God and
eating the Apple
it's like fair enough you know looks
like she slipped up and then she tempted
her husband and you know that makes her
even worse although he's was foolish
enough to immediately eat so it just
means she was a little more courageous
than him and got there first
but it's Adam who comes across as really
one sad creature in this story as far as
I'm concerned well come on he manages in
one sentence it's like first of all it
wasn't him it was the woman and citizen
even blames God more than just the woman
it was that woman and you gave her to me
and she gave me of the tree and I did
eat it's like so hey Adams all innocent
except now he's not only is he naked and
disobedient and cowardly and ashamed
he's also snively backbiting think he
wraps her out like the second he gets
the opportunity and then he blames God
it's like and that's exactly right
that's exactly right man you go online
and you read you read the commentary
that then write about women when they're
resentful and bitter about women you
read it it's so interesting it's like
it's not me it's those bitches okay
that's right it's not me it's them and
not only that
bloody world this is in which they exist
it's exactly the same thing it's exactly
the same thing and it is absolutely
pathetic all right
[Applause]